la première la première j'ai déjà dit
j'ai surveillé géraldine nakache
coloniale
ouais ouais ouais on est parti une fois
ensemble en colonies ou 2 2 weight avait
une copine s'appelait vanessa hubbell
exactement il embrasse et tu aimais
beaucoup ça oui alors j'ai une question
parce que il dit toujours qu aucune mais
ce n'est son style à l'époque c'était
quoi son style alors c'était quand même
déjà très éclectique
[Rires]
ouais ouais ouais entre d'artagnan java
délires capillaires
ouais c'est plutôt la souveraine
alex tu peux y aller jean cyr croiser
quelques années plus tard à comédie sur
la chaîne comédie en 2002 hélas le
dossier c'est pour toi j'ai un petit
doute pour toi je chantais et toi tu
faisais des petites chorégraphies
je me rappelle ou dernièrement au
derrière cades mais je n'étais déjà très
très sympathique nous gave
[Musique]
ensemble
compilation des sosies aux bijoux la fia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
doit elle choquée elle est à fond dans
tous les débats extrêmement web ouvert
aux professionnels dans son travail des
falaises derrière bravo et voilà et
apache en juillet après changé